hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast quantifying micro RNA and
protein biomarkers directly from
challenging sample types with fire flex
technology it is presented by Brendan
Collins field scientific specialist for
the eastern US for multiplex assays a
tab cam I am Julia Rourke of lab routes
then I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes and sponsored by ab cam for more
information about our sponsor
visit www.sap.com/learnbi nose
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box it
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming Brendan I will now
turn the presentation over to him a
brand name of fire clicks because due to
the fireplace particle technology these
essays and I'll take you through that in
a few slides so what I'm gonna talk
about today is quantifying Micro Renee
and protein biomarkers directly from
challenging sample types while using
this fireplace technology today we'll
take you through a brief overview of the
firebox technology and the particles and
how this works then I'll take you
through our different assays that
utilize these particles I'll take you
through our standard fire puts mic RNA
and
you know essays these allow you to
multiplex up to 75 analytes in a single
well and then I'll talk to you about our
brand new no wash - USA this is a high
to quit audible so this is an
introduction to the Firefox platform
firebox platform is a very new
technology it uses optical liquid
stamping of hydrogels to create a large
particle which is a rod-shaped particle
these are then conjugated to either
antibodies or probes to capture either
protein or mica or micro rna's in so
they're designed specifically for
biomarker discovery and verification
with the micro and a say you can profile
directly from biofuels this RNA
purification so directly profile micro a
present serum plasma exosomes
urine cerebral spinal fluid we even
recently have launched a direct from
tissue formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue and cell suspensions for the
protein as the coating presentation
actually i mean you know a say you can
directly conjugate you can directly
profile proteins samples from plasma
serum urine
yes definitely this is here's a picture
of the particle so the card equals a
large rod shaped a hydrogel particle
made of peg so it's biologically inert
it allows for optical thermodynamics
because it's sort of like a sponge so it
allows samples to throw the particle and
get optimal binding throughout the
particle as opposed to just on the
surface of say AP it's inert so you
won't have as other binding nonspecific
binding to the particle from your sample
each end is is fluorescently labeled
with a dye these are what create
so the codes are different levels of
intensity zuv yellow green and that
corresponds to each code specifically
corresponds to what is conjugated in the
middle which would be their specific
antibody to specific protein or a probe
to my carne sequence and this is how you
can get to 75 in a single well because
there are 75 different codes
it's then read out on a flow cytometry
or a high content imager the flow
cytometry is what our standard assays
were used to read out and it runs
through the Saitama door single file and
and you end up getting three events and
then in this high content imager it
takes a picture of the well and you'll
end up seeing the different codes and
the different intensities of yellow
green and red and I forgot to mention
earlier the middle region is write out
as a red dye because we add a red
reporter which I'll take through in a
few slides the assay workflow and
that'll make more sense they're the very
light gray region or just plain this is
all allowed spacing between the three
fluorescent dyes your site ometer can
distinguish between the three events we
also provide a free of charge software
and so what you end up doing is you take
your FCS file from your close hectometer
or your tiff file from your high content
imager import that into our software and
that will decode the particles
corresponding to which specific analyte
or and then it will quantify these for
you or normalize the data this is a
screenshot of our micro na sa software
this is a heat map so this shows
differential expression micro RNA and
different sample types depending on
which mic RNA is in the panel you can
organize your plate layout here you can
create heat maps bar plots all sorts of
do all sorts of statistical analyses
here we actually can create publication
quality figures with our software and we
ever had dozens of publications with our
asset
this is a screenshot of what the
immunoassay would look like so these are
standard curves which you can designate
on deplete and quantify your proteins
and your samples this much like analyzer
we also offer a service lab in Boston
this is really useful for someone that
may not have a site ometer or high
content imager you can send us your
samples will do the surfaces for you
we'll run the full assay we typically
turn the project around within 15
business days maybe another week or two
if it's a custom panel which we do offer
and I will get to that later
well we not only just do the assay and
sending the data we send you a detailed
report of what this data actually means
and we're happy to talk with you after
the project is done go through the data
with you so now I'll take you through
our five books micro asset this is a the
assay overview so it takes about a day
to run so you start with your tissue or
your bio fluid with bio fluid you can
work from 20 microliters of sample input
this is really useful if you're working
with mouse or rat and you may not have a
lot of sample to choose from so you add
our digest buffer to the sample and that
will release the micro names in your
sample and then you add the panel which
contains the probe the particles with
the specific microRNAs that you're
looking for in your sample after
incubation the panel you hybridize and
you're actually going to elute the bound
of microRNAs off of the particle of
course after you wash after you wash you
will loot it off and then you're gonna
run PCR and I will take you through the
molecular workflow in the next slide so
with PCR amplifying and then at the end
of that you actually have a biotin
elated complex and you're gonna end up
translating them back to the plate
recapturing onto the same particle makes
you had before and then add a reporter
which is to step down a piece at five to
give you the red dye the red readout and
then you can scan it in your flow
cytometry and analyze in our software
this is the molecular workflow so it's
really helpful to see with how this
actually works from this level so these
are different particles as you can see
the blue region is where the probe is
conjugated to there are millions of
binding sites here the light gray
regions on each end of the probe or what
we call the universal label region these
are the same sequences throughout the
particles no matter of which Mike Renee
they're trying to capture whereas the
blue region in the middle this is the
target specific region so this target
this is the sequence specific to the
micro RNA you're looking for so you had
your sample and this probe captured Mike
Renee 16 another one will capture Mike
her name or etc up to 70 different Mike
RNAs in the sample and then after you
have the micro negging bound you were
gonna wash and you're gonna add a
universal labeled mix these will bind to
each end of the universal label regions
one of these labeling mixes has a little
bit of myself once you have the complex
which is the universal label captured
Mike Renee specific to what you're
looking for and then the universal label
on the other end
it creates the complex and then you
elude it off and you run PCR you're
gonna run PCR with universal primers
against these Universal regions not the
target specific region so your because
these are the same Universal regions
regardless of which probe they are it'll
amplify equally across all of the micro
RNAs and on one of these primers is a
biotin so that allows you to add the
strip dabbed in peace v sy v dye to get
the fluorescent read o so once you've
amplified you have your biotin biotin
elated complex of mic RNA Universal
label you capture it back on the same
part of the mixer you captured earlier
in your samples and
you add a reporter to get the
fluorescent readout and then you run it
through the solicitor and import it to
our software so this is an example of
heat map of panel that we used on
different sample types so this is a 65
plex panel capturing different microRNAs
and different sample types these highly
expressed these are lower expressed but
as you can see with plasma EDTA plasma
heparin serum he's all worked really
well and very consistently we've also
worked with amniotic fluid exome prep
saliva formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
tissue and even purified RNA so for
sample input for file foods we only
require 20 microliters for tissue
sections we only require 5 micron curls
again none of this requires RNA
isolation ahead of time or cDNA
preparation of pre amplification you can
work directly with your samples which
makes it very easy to work with and if
you have purified RNA already that's
totally fine you would just skip the
digest up and work right with the panel
capturing the micro native interest so
I'll take you through some data how this
asset how we validated this assay so
this is this is how we've determined the
20 microliters of sample input based on
the sensitivity of the assay so we
certainly with the custom 48 Plex panel
and when we added pooled human serum we
added 40 microliters and 20 microliters
10 5 and 0 Michael years we saw no
difference between 40 microliters and 20
microliters of sample of sample input
these captured on average 35 Mike rnase
of the 48 and the other 13 just mean
that they weren't present in the sample
and then when you when we added 10
microliters of sample it only reduced it
down to an average of 29 or 30 so we
lost a few micro nays that were lower
expressed but you can still go down to
five and still capture
fifteen to twenty my carting so this is
where we determined that 20 microliters
ism is a really good input amount it
really makes no difference before tea
and then it saves you sample it allows
you to run duplicate if you only have 50
microliters and over here this is brain
lung and liver reference RNA and this
just shows that we are able to capture
my carne and lower inputs of picograms
of RNA this slide shows the specificity
of the assay so we were able to
distinguish single nucleotide
discrimination within families and
closely related migraines here we had a
panel two panels one was a led seven
family and one was a 302 family by car
names with very small differences of
sequences we were still able to
distinguish to distinguish relatively we
were still able to specifically
distinguish these Mike RNA from the
other and of course some of them hired
because it really depends on where those
changes fall on the molecular level like
if they're on the end of the sequence
they're still going to get binding and
you might have a floating tail there but
overall it's very specific this slide
shows the reproducibility we've done the
assay at different days and we were able
to show these still strongly correlated
appending on what day you run in the
panel and the same samples and this
slide shows that we are able to profile
in samples containing inhibitors without
any issue
so a lot of times you might have samples
as plasma samples with heparin or sodium
citrate where that might not work
because of the inhibitors in those in
those samples but due to all the wash
steps that we have before you even find
the for even run PCR you're going to
wash the samples to wash away any of the
of the inhibitors in those samples so by
the time you're absolutely running PCR
those are all gone
this slide shows is a platform
comparison of but the fire puts a say
versus tilde cards in alumina to sneak
we have strong correlation between the
three to three essays and in fact we
have a smaller sample input and it just
strongly correlates so now I'll take you
through what we have to offer for the
micro math essay so we essentially have
three different types of panels that we
offer the first one I'll talk about is
our discovery panels
so these identify Mike Renee signature
invites good samples like plasma serum
and filters super mean these are
pre-designed panels of 400 circulating
microRNAs so these are 400 microliters
Migron a selected from peer-reviewed
studies we have a plasma serum of this
panel an immunology focused panel and a
rodent specific panel or if you're
working with mouse or rat soon we're
gonna be releasing a seal against panel
and a viral mic running panel so this is
really useful if you aren't really sure
which mic Renee and Mike in your sample
you might have an idea of song but there
might be others you might not have
considered this actually requires a
little bit of more sample input because
it's going to be split across across
wells you can do about 12 samples per
plate but essentially you're gonna get
four into mic Renee's out of your sample
what a lot of our customers do is
they'll do a small study with the
discovery panel then they're able to see
you know at least 35 these 40 my car
days actually show strong differential
expression now we want to study these
further and then we can design a custom
panel for you which I'll talk about we
also have focus panels so these are
smaller focused panels that are specific
to different research areas like
oncology immunology neurology and
cardiology we also have different tissue
toxicity panels for kidney liver
pancreas and cardiac
city these are the 65 Mike Rene's single
well in a single well this would be with
your 20 microliters sampling but so
these are more focused if you're
specifically looking at this area of
research and finally the best offering I
think that we have is our custom panels
we can build the custom panel to any
Mike reading sequence that you're
looking for so we've had some customers
do very small panels screening across a
large number of samples we can go
through five Mike Rene's up to 200 so if
you're working with you know a different
species that we might not that might not
have homology with mouse rat and human
we can build that as long as you have a
sequence like canine monkey etc if
there's some novel microRNAs that might
not be in any more focus panels we can
build those too as long as we have a
sequence where as long as if it's an ear
bass version 21 we can design that for
you so here's an example of some custom
maker Mike are any panels that customers
might use they might want to design a
panel for macrophages or dendritic cells
or T cells we have a really useful fire
effect discovery engine tool that I'll
take you through in the next slide
essentially what it does is it searches
pubmed and it searches all the abstract
words and makes a word cloud of the most
popular most cited words in those
abstracts depending on which area of
research you're looking for so this is a
word cloud or someone searched for
macrophages probably human and these are
the most commonly cited in my car days
and the what's really useful is the
discovery engine actually links you to
those pubmed articles you can actually
click on the read here's another example
of custom my chronic panel that someone
might design for organ injury the link
is down here of our fire effects
discovery engine this is what it looks
like essentially it's just a little
search bar like a Google you type in
oncology you select the species of
interest
you can search and then you get the word
cloud you'll also get oh this is a
screenshot of what it looks like so this
will be the word vowed here these are
the most commonly used cited words these
are the most commonly cited genes and
these are the most commonly cited
authors and these actually all are
hyperlinks so you can click on them
directly now we'll take you through our
multiplex amino acids the amino acids
are essentially Eliza's run instead of
on the instead of the cashier and a body
being on the bottom of your Eliza of
United States will plate the capture
antibody is on particle itself with a
specific code corresponding to that
antibody in this assay you'd only
require is 12 and a half microliters of
bio fluid input this can multiplex up to
75 minutes analytes in a single well so
you add your capture antibody that
capture antibody detects the protein of
interest so if this is Tina fellow it'll
capture tnf-alpha in your sample we we
provide the detector antibody which is
biotin elated and then you added by a
stripped Avenue piece that I've reporter
died and you run it through the flow
cytometry micro micro rnas a and then
you import that into our software for
analysis here's here's the workflow
details slide so again capture wash
detect your antibody wash you only need
to incubate for an hour at room temp for
each of these you could also do an
overnight incubation at 4 degrees if you
want we're pretty flexible that way then
after the last wash you had your piece
i5 and you imported you rent this and
close automata and you import our
software this will plot your standard
curve we provide the standard curve
mixes so if it's you know one of our 17
flex key cytokine panels we would
provide you with mix a which has all 17
of those in a single mix here's a couple
of our pre-designed human panels we have
an inflammation panel key cytokines and
complex panel key cytokine four-plex and
a th1 th2 response panel we also have
the same offering for mouse rat and
non-human primate analytes this is a
screen shot of the dynamic range of the
sensitivity of our top 17 key cytokine
panel so these assays all use our rabid
monoclonal antibody pairs we all of
these pairs are produced in-house at
Afghan they're common in monoclonal
antibodies so because of that they are
highly sensitive they have very strong
lock to lock correlation because they're
recombinant antibodies actually they
also have a really broad dynamic range
which is really useful if you're trying
to you know measure you know healthy
versus sick patients you can see strong
inflammation spikes without it going
over the dynamic range depending on the
analyte of interest most of our a good
about half or most of our analytes have
higher sensitivity than our competitors
these these would be the ones in purple
highlight here yeah this is depent this
is based off of what our competitors
have put online their cytokine panels
and as you can see we have a four to
five log dynamic range here for all of
them in the same wall which is really
useful so instead of having to run 17
different Eliza's you can just do one
assay here and it saves you a ton of
time and a ton of money we also have a
70 plex pre-designed panel this is this
was launched a few at 72 bucks sorry
this was launched a few weeks ago we've
had a couple customers running very
successfully in our service lab so far
this is a list of the 236 plex panels we
have panel a in panel B which you can
get as well but the 72 flex is just a
combination of panel a in panel B and
these are a list of all the analytes you
can profile in your sent in your sample
only twelve and a half microliters you
can capture all
these proteins in a single well and as
far as we're aware it's the larger
largest multiplex amino acid and a
little currently on the market this is a
screenshot of the dynamic range of the
70 plex panel so they spike them all
being in one well they still have really
strong dynamic range here and some of
these have really low sensitivities
single sub picogram we we screen these
and all sorts of samples so we've
screened this 70 Plex in in plasma EDTA
heparin and citrate plasma in cell puts
a supernatant
CSF and urine and serum so we're
releasing a 70 Plex Mouse iodine panel
as well this should be PTAs October 2018
so coming up really soon these should
have very similar markers as the ones
here in the 70 bucks panel we also offer
custom amino acid panels for this is
another example where you can design
your own panel for oncology research say
for cytokine release syndrome or immuno
oncology markers if it's a subset of
their 70 Plex panels since we've screen
these pairs together we validated these
all together we can just design you a
custom panel of that we're also
releasing some organ injury and toxicity
panels very soon as well so kidney tox
cardiac talks and their liver talks
about our simple step eliza kits and our
fire bucks assays have very strong
correlation in fact most of the pair is
actually are the same in the simple
several advocates as they are in the
firefox asset so if you were to screen
say our 17 flex key cytokine and then
you're looking at just you want to just
look at TNF alpha across more samples
you can get a simple stubble as a kid
it's the exact same pair that was used
in our firefights assay so the essay
itself takes about 90 minutes 2 hours to
run and then scanning on the site ometer
you can you can analyze up to 75
analytes Pro well from only 12 and a
half microliters of sample input
straight out out of 96 well plate and
then on a photometer the sensitivity
depending on the analyte is for the most
part sub picogram per mil and again is 4
to 5 full dynamic range and less than
50% a little CV and is compatible on
lots of biofluids like plasma serum so
the supernatant CSF urine about the
again this is the the reason why this is
so able to get 70 samples 70 analytes in
a single well and have such high
sensitivity is because of the
recombinant monoclonal antibody again
because their monoclonal is low cross
reactivity across samples it's for
comment so you get low a lot to lot
variability and you get high sensitivity
as well these these are these antibody
pairs are in our multiplex immunoassays
fire plants and particles the simple sub
lattice we also offer matched in about a
pair kits so if you want to scale up
Eliza's you can get matched antibody
pairs now I'll take you to our fire
flicks high throughput immunoassay this
is brand new products launched in July
so this is for high-throughput screening
and it's very similar to be immunoassay
just discussed in fact it's a simpler
workflow which is you know key for a
high cookbook so you had a fire punch
reagent mix to your samples so one of
our panels to the to your biological
samples it only requires six point two
five microliters of sample input so
you're gonna add 625 microliters of your
sample to six point two five Mike liters
the antibody mix panel mix you're going
to incubate overnight at room
temperature and then you're going to add
a imaging
the imaging dye will quench any excess
autofluorescence within the sample so
this is key for an hola high-capacity
the particles all then settle to the
bottom of the well the imaging guide
punches everything in your sample and
everything not found in your sample any
autofluorescence that might occur and
then you put put it through a high
content imager and it'll take a picture
of the well these are read out on 384
well place so this is really useful if
you're screening hundreds to thousands
of samples the reason why the high
content imagers really useful is because
it only takes ten or twenty minutes to
scan the whole plane ticket picture as
opposed to a flow cytometry which might
take an hour and a half to two and a
half hours depending on the site ama 496
monthly so if you think 384 Wells in 20
minutes or 96 miles an hour and a half
to two hours this is way better for
high-throughput screening you take the
image file and directly import into our
software which is the same one you
download for the Mike Renee and the
standard in USA and you do the same data
analysis as you would before so we
validated a couple imagers so far they
would image express from molecular
devices TTP lab techs Mirrorball for
canola offer Phoenix a few others this
is a really useful picture because I
think it's really nice because you can
actually see the particles you can
actually see the codes and the analytes
captured with the red dye so if you look
closely you can see different levels of
green and yellow combinations with red
in the middle and those are the that's
the particle ends and those are the dot
that codes to correspond to specific
protein that's captured the red is again
the antibody that's capture the protein
and the different levels of intensity of
those just implies the different
quantities in that sample of that
particle in that sample
these are some of the analytes we've
validated so far so we've done about 30
so they still have a pretty high
sensitivity for no launch a say again
you can't compare to the standard
immediate last a because of how many
washed steps that are you're gonna get
better sensitivity but even with no wash
we're still able to get fairly low
sensitivity while maintaining two to
three log dynamic range these are some
here are some of the panels available we
have a human 10th Lex human six Plex
panel these are key cytokines we're also
developing a interferon at six effects
panel that should be coming very soon
this is some of the panel validation so
this is the analyte performance you can
see that it still has excuse me still
has three to four full dynamic range it
has very low cross reactivity these are
all that this is fifteen to twenty
different analytes prospectivity
and we did a spike recovery and all of
these show for the most part was in 30
percent
the high-throughput assays also designed
to be automatable for for those that
want to automate and not many plates in
a day so we are able to do this and
we're having to discuss this with you so
for the high throughput immunoassay
again so it's up to ten analytes per
well as opposed to 75 and the standard
immunoassay the reason for this is
because the three a four wells are very
small you're adding much less sample and
the particles themselves are actually
fairly large and because you're taking a
picture you don't want them to be
stacking on top of one another
otherwise you won't be able to
distinguish so we found that with the
amount of analytes with the amount of
particles we put in per analyte ten is
the optimal amount but it's red on
384-well plate so you can get much more
samples out of this to write on a high
content image so it's much faster
because I'd only twenty minutes to scan
sensitivity is still one 200 pica grams
per mil for no Lajeunesse a and again
6.5 liters of sample this is validated
so far serum plasma and subtlety super
named we're working on other sample
types to finally I wanted to mention
that app Kim also has custom antibody
development this is a flexible fullcycle
support of custom and web development so
consult with us we can produce grab maps
for you can NDS for you face display etc
we have experienced specialists in
antibody design that can support you
every step of the way you can even think
about a custom Android design for used
in fire flex as well
thank you so much I'm happy to answer
any questions Thank You Brendan for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email let's get
started our first question is does this
work on tissue or cells directly and
release the Micra names and then our
panel thank you which flow cytometry and
imagers are validated so many
photometers are to test a lot of the
beedi machines you can reach out to us
and ask you have a fueled application
scientist that can work with you
directly to help set up the site ah
meters or the imagers and for you before
you start the essay and what we do is we
provide a we have a particle of what we
call Saitama ters setup kit or a imager
setup kit these are particles without
probe or antibody in them but just the
dyes so you can run them through the
Saitama ters it takes images of those
ahead of time before you use any samples
or any of our panels to make sure that
those are calibrated ahead of time thank
you for that next how much sample input
does this require input for the bio food
assay for microRNAs
for the micron is a bio fluid sample
input it's 20 microliters you can go
down to the lower amounts if needed if
you have less but 20 microliters is
optimal for the immunoassay the standard
name University apologies is the 12 and
a half Michael ears for the high
throughput assay thank you of time for
one more question
do you have to extract RNA no you don't
have to probe out directly from the but
if you happen to have already extracted
RNA that's totally fine it'll still work
with our assay thank you I'd like to
once again thank Brenton Collins for his
presentation would also like to thank AB
cam for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December 27th 2018 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that is
all for now thank you for joining us we
hope to see you again soon bye